bonjour bonjour
c'est une grosse journée c'est la
journée où on lance la guignolée des
médias en effet bon est-ce que croiser
les doigts où vous êtes à peu près sûr
du résultat
on sait ce soir il va en avoir assez
écouté on peut présumer de rien mais on
est certain que les Québécois sont
généreux c'est sûr qu'il y a des défis
cette année on parle d'inflation
beaucoup dans les médias on peut pas
l'ignorer mais on insulte quand même les
gens à donner à la hauteur de leurs
besoins de leur capacité vous dites les
Québécois sont généreux en même temps
les besoins n'ont jamais été aussi grand
on a voulu sentez vous êtes nouvelle ici
c'est intéressant vous avez une nouvelle
vision vous arrivez depuis quelques mois
tout à fait les besoins sont énormes
c'est ce qui est le plus vertigineux ici
c'est ce qui m'a le plus
surpris en arrivant ici définitivement
toute la marchandises qui rentre ici à
24 48 heures elle ressort alors on n'est
pas en mesure d'avoir de l'inventaire à
plus finir c'est vraiment la rotation de
la marchandise se fait très rapidement
puisqu'on voit là qu'est-ce qu'ils font
ces destiné à qui tout d'abord c'est de
la marchandise qu'on reçoit beaucoup des
marchands des épiceries entre autres de
certains donateurs on classe la
marchandise parce qu'exemple on reçoit
des boissons gazeuses on les met de côté
on reçoit de la nourriture pour les
animaux ou des produits d'hygiène on les
met de côté et les boîtes sont en train
de se monter c'est de la nourriture
uniquement qui va là-dedans les autres
produits c'est mis à part alors toutes
ces boîtes là vont être préparées et
ensuite vont être remises aux organismes
c'est un peu comme des boîtes surprises
les organismes adorent ça parce que
plein de choses à l'intérieur et là il y
a plusieurs organismes dans l'écosystème
dans la prenons la grande région de
Montréal est-ce que ils vont en recevoir
assez
écoutez nous on descend 300 organismes
sur l'île de Montréal on doit c'est
énorme mais en même temps c'est pas
l'entièreté est-ce qu'ils vont recevoir
assez je vais être honnête avec vous non
les besoins sont trop grands mais on ose
espérer qu'on compte quand même une très
grande partie de ses besoins-là et puis
ça leur permet de faire de réaliser leur
mission en fait ce qu'on fait comme
travail mais eux ont pas besoin d'aller
chercher des denrées supplémentaires
intéressant parce que vous venez
d'arriver il y a quelques mois puis vous
suiviez les nouvelles depuis les années
comme tout le monde puis on le répète
les besoins sont énormes on dirait que
là vous avez les deux pieds dedans ça
vous amène surprise ben tout à fait tout
à fait je veux rentrer dans un entrepôt
de la grandeur d'ici c'est plus de
100000 pieds carrés quand même alors de
voir que autant de capacités
d'entreposage et qu'on ne suffit pas à
la tâche alors c'est impressionnant la
clientèle change aussi au niveau de
l'aide alimentaire il y avait une
certaine clientèle qui en avait besoin
auparavant aujourd'hui c'est tout le
monde qui pourrait en avoir besoin
le matin donc ça demande explose à cause
de ça aussi les 300 organismes
quand il y en a pas assez vous rappelle
puis vous êtes obligé de leur dire non
est-ce que ça vous mais ça nous arrive
tout à fait oui oui ça nous arrive ça
nous arrive mais on essaie quand même
j'ai une équipe de trois personnes à
temps complet qui font ce qu'on appelle
du recrutement de donateurs qui font
aussi les contacts avec les épiceries on
a quand même 7 camions qui roulent 6
jours par semaine alors il y a quand
même une infrastructure ici qu'on a mis
en place dans les derniers mois pour
justement aller chercher le maximum de
dons puis on travaille en collaboration
avec d'autres moissons aussi mais ici
c'est 58 personnes qui travaillent à
temps complet en plus de bénévoles pour
faire en sorte qu'il y a de la
marchandise qui rentre mais qu'elle
puisse sortir aussi vous vous promenez
du monde
alimentaire vous étiez chez Costco entre
vous connaissez bien ce monde là est-ce
que les grands détaillants
mère a donné plus ou ça vaut mieux
moi je vous dirais que ce que je perçois
jusqu'à maintenant les gens font
vraiment leur part je dis pas qu'il y a
pas une capacité d'en faire plus
sûrement mais je pense que tous les
maillons de la chaîne sont assez bien
sollicités mais il faut qu'on trouve une
façon je pense dans notre travail d'être
plus créatif peut-être d'être innovant
puis de travailler davantage ensemble
pour maximiser les denrées alors toute
la journée ça va sortir ici là oui ici
c'est notre emplacement ou justement les
organismes viennent vous avez vraiment
le comme on dit le direct nous on est un
système de précommande donc les
organismes
arrivent avec leur véhicule puis emporte
les systèmes de précommande ils peuvent
commander à l'avance certains produits
selon les inventaires qu'on a donc nous
on les prépare c'est comme englo pour
accélérer le processus aussi parce que à
300 il faut quand même que ça roule et
une fois qu'ils ont leur précommande est
faite ils peuvent se promener il y a des
emplacements de l'autre côté où il y a
entre autres les d'Israël les fruits et
légumes ils peuvent faire le taupe et
bonifier leur commande quand les gens
vous demandent ça revient beaucoup cette
question là ce qu'on est mieux de donner
de l'argent ou des denrées qu'on a chez
nous qu'est-ce que vous répondez écoutez
les besoins sont là qu'on va prendre les
deux on va prendre les deux on va
prendre les deux mais par contre une
façon de donner des dents et dans le
sens que c'est sûr que si les gens
veulent faire des collègues veulent
venir les porter ici dans le cas de la
guignoler on est quand même trois
organisations sur Montréal on va
partager ou encore il y a les maxi
Provigo où on peut aller porter des
denrées donc ça c'est plus facile aussi
après pour nous d'aller les chercher
puis les redistribuer et ça va c'est
important de le dire ça finit pas c'est
pas une journée la guingolée aujourd'hui
non c'est jusqu'à la fin du mois de
décembre donc tout le mois de décembre
on sensibilise les gens à donner à la
hauteur encore là de leur capacités mais
aussi le site de la guignolet reçoit des
dons toute l'année aussi c'est un site
qui est actif parce que la fin c'est 12
mois par année
vous allez rester quelques années à moi
sur mon
oui ça va bien oui moi pour moi
c'est un cadeau pour moi de gérer moi
sur Montréal c'est une équipe formidable
ici les gens employés sont extrêmement
dédiés à la cause puis à la sécurité
alimentaire c'est 50 bénévoles minimum
par jour qui viennent ici il y a déjà
qui viennent chaque jour depuis
plusieurs années alors le taux
d'engagement est incroyable c'est un
privilège pour une gestionnaire de gérer
moi sur Montréal merci beaucoup madame
merci à vous merci